d'abord mais d'abord le parti
présidentiel qui reprend la main après
un agenda médiatique de cette semaine
dominée par la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et socialiste le parti
présidentiel qui présente ses premiers
candidats aux 10 l'atvs sous une
nouvelle bannière donc un sujet signé
mathias arese
à défaut d'une maison commune chère à
emmanuel macron c'est la création d'une
confédération que vient d'acter la
majorité présidentielle un accord
politique
électorale pour investir les candidates
et les candidats aux élections
législatives du prochain mois de juin
renaissance le modem et horizons sont
donc les trois membres fondateurs
d'ensemble objectif remporter la
bataille des législatives et offrir au
président la majorité la plus large
possible l'ambition programmatique a été
posée au moment de la campagne
présidentielle par le président de la
république et nous nous inscrivons dans
cette logique après un dernier comité
exécutif la nouvelle machine électorale
estampillé emmanuel macron à statuer sur
ces équilibres ainsi le parti d'edouard
philippe récupérer 58 circonscription le
modem et françois bayrou sans une le
reste pour l'ancienne république en
marche concernant les tractations avec
les républicains richard ferrand qui
présidera la structure a précisé que
pour bénéficier d'un appui il faudrait
remplir trois conditions
qu'il souscrit au projet présidentiel
sans réserve 2 que dans le cadre de son
travail avec la liberté qu'ont les
députés évidemment tout cas et ça dans
une logique majoritaire de te
construction
est naturellement qu'ils viendraient
rejoindre ladite formation ou l'une de
celles qui sont représentés ce jeudi 200
investiture ensemble ont été rendus
publics une prochaine salve devrait
intervenir dans les prochains jours
avant une journée travail et formation
pour tous les candidats le 10 mai
c'est presque un titre version
antiquaires que je vous proposais belle
macro période renaissance on en débat
tout de suite avec mes invités alexia
germond bonsoir vous êtes présidente
fondatrice du cercle de réflexion france
audacieuse délégué municipal du comité
horizons dans le 15e arrondissement à
paris michel wieviorka bonsoir bienvenue
d'être sociologue directeur d'études à
l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales et vous publiez
ces jours ci alors monsieur macron
heureux aux éditions rue de seine
benjamin morel bonsoir soit maître de
conférences en droit public à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
bienvenue à vous aussi et bienvenue à
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir dans une première
réaction à ce nouveau nom renaissance je
n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de faire mon
intéressant pourrait ouvrir cette cette
séquence mais est-ce que c'est pas un
peu pompeux quand même à l'excès a germé
et coûté en tout cas pour ceux qui se
souviennent des élections européennes
c'est clair que on voit bien le le le le
monde c'est le nom de la liste donc ça
montre aussi du point de vue symbolique
quand même l'ancrage programmatique sur
l'europe et on sait très bien on revient
un petit peu en arrière mais au moment
des présidentielles il y avait vraiment
des clivages autour d'une position
européenne ce qui était vraiment
européens assumer ou non donc on peut
voir recette cette transition là
après il faut avoir il faut bien
distinguer en fait à la fois la
transformation du nom du parti la
république en marche qui doit être
pérenne aussi on sait bien qu'il faut
redonner de l'élan pour ce quinquennat
et avec un maillage territorial et puis
vous avez aussi la bannière plus
électoral ensemble qui fait écho au site
est une poursuite semble-t-il quand même
du thème de campagne qu'on avait eu
puisque c'était avec vous c'était 50
plus mais avec vous et on voit bien la
transition est ce que moi ce qui
m'intéresse dans derrière le ensemble
finalement c'est que ça veut donc bien
dire qu'il ya des identités différentes
qui dit ensemble d'idées précision
différentes et vous avez trois membres
vous avez trois partis fondateurs et on
voit que pour donner une majorité stable
une majorité présidentielle stable et
qui permette l'action parce que c'est
surtout ça le sujet si on met de côté
les accords là évidemment on est sur les
accords plus électoralistes mais à quoi
ça sert ça sert surtout à pouvoir faire
que ce quinquennat soit une réussite
parce que vous avez 5 ans devant vous
qui sont cinq ans où il y a
vraiment des problématiques dans tous
les coins sur lesquels il va falloir
arriver à rassembler le plus largement
possible pour avoir une éthique de
gouvernement qui permettent de faire que
les français s'en sortent mieux michel
wieviorka ce nouveau nom renaissant est
ce que pour vous il ya un sens politique
si on prend le la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale les mots
finalement donne l'une des différentes
tonalités qui se réunissent alors on en
parlait un peu plus tard dans ce débat
mais au sein de au sein de cette
alliance est ce que là le nom rené
santos a du sens ça a du sens mais ça
n'a pas un sens de contenu ou alors
d'abord il faut dire les choses
renaissance re ça veut dire
on serait peut être et naissance on se
transforme donc c'est l'idée qu'on se
transforme en se répétant il ya un petit
peu de ça dans mon renaissance puis
deuxièmement il a grandes périodes
historiques qu'on appelle la renaissance
en essence on sort des ténèbres on va
vers vers la modernité
il y aura du changement et donc c'est
peut-être un peu audacieux ça sonne un
peu comment dire est vintage enfin j'ai
passé un petit côté
pas d'actualité c'est peut-être ce qui
est voulu mais ça ne dit rien du tout du
contenu d'un programme d'une division et
le ensemble que vous que vous venez
d'évoquer pts et on prend les mêmes et
on recommence c'est quand même très
impressionnant donc ensemble oui mais en
somme avec les mêmes tons l'instant je
dirais dire que des hommes moi j'essaie
des choses qui me qui me fera bon on ne
voit que des hommes dans ces images que
vous nous avez donné
à voir le côté ensemble et le côté
renaissance c'est pas très tard et être
un peu bien sûr bien sûr rien il ya eu
une la parité au sein des gouvernements
mais effectivement plus on se rapproche
du pouvoir macro nist et notamment au
sein de ses équipes à élise c'est vrai
que là les femmes sont peu nombreuses
mais jade morel c'est juste du marketing
politique oui c'est du marketing
politique et c'est du marketing on doit
dire très très marketing à ces
politiques ne dire que quand vous avez
le mot socialiste vous instaurez un
clivage quand vous avez le mot droite
gaulliste ex ha ha vous instaurez un
clivage là en fait tout le monde pour y
reprendre le thème renaissance ou
ensemble donc on est vraiment dans ce
qui fait aujourd'hui le marketing
politique avec des signifiants vide des
choses qui en réalité ne sont là pour
fâcher personne et ça signifie en
réalité deux choses de premièrement que
vous avez pas d'identité politique qui
s'est développé autour de la macro ni
depuis cinq ans vous avez un leader un
chef dont on voit aux élections
intermédiaires que quand il est absent
directement en première ligne eh bien ça
ne se passe pas très bien c'est à dire
que c'est vraiment l'adhésion à un homme
est beaucoup plus à une identité ou un
espace politique et ça ça peut poser
problème à ces élections parce que si
jamais vous avez une partie de
l'électorat qui décident de voter
d'entités politiques et qui voit
ensemble renaissance et mais risquent de
ne pas tout à fait comprendre est
toujours un risque en changeant de
marque parce qu'en changeant de marque
eh bien vous troubler l'électorat vous
lui fait perdre des habitudes des
signifiants que malgré tout au bout de
cinq ans il avait fini par à peu près
six tués et comprendre ensuite le
deuxième élément est bien c'est que dans
le cadre de ces élections si vous avez
insignifiant qui apparaît beaucoup trop
vide vous avez un risque en réalité est
bien de recréer un effet qui va être un
effet de relocalisation de l'élection ce
sûr qu'aujourd'hui joue une partie du ps
et de l air en dix ans grosso modo vous
sortons ne sont pas implantées regardez
nous nous avons un ancrage sur le
terrain etc nous existons depuis
longtemps donc continuer à voter pour
nous ça va pas changer les élections
c'est parce que je suis en train de vous
dire et je suis pas sûr que
politiquement à ce stade là d'une
compagne ce soit fondamentalement
habilement mathieu ses classiques un
changement de nom en politique oui entre
nous on vient de le dire un peu c'est
pas forcément bon signe
quand on change de nom qu'on rit pauline
la façade comme dirait le président
c'est qu'on veut en finir avec le passé
et dessiner une nouvelle ambition 17
démontré par une marque que l'on n'est
plus tout à fait les mêmes sans être
vraiment différent
stanislas gary neal patron de l'ancienne
république en marche a donc jeté son
dévolu sur renaissance à c'est un joli
nom en essence c'est empreint d'histoire
on l'a dit bien sûr ça marque une époque
celle des grandes découvertes celles de
l'humanisme celle de l'apparition de la
langue française les références sont
évidentes les historiens taquin
soulignons quand même qu'avec la
renaissance on est à peine sorti du
moyen-age on n'est pas encore tout à
fait rentrer dans les temps modernes
mais après tout pourquoi pas et puis
stanislas guérini qui jongle avec les
références historiques quand même
pizzaïolo et ses ingrédients a même
parlé de de lumière et de lutte contre
l'obscurantisme aurait fait un bond de
siècle pourquoi pas mais en tout cas
voilà sert les sens et c'est pas grave
on remarquera au passage comme l'a fait
michel wievorka que eric zemmour lui a
fait choisir reconquête emmanuel macron
choisir renaissance il y à du rheu dans
l'air et donc que ce préfixe re qui
exprime c'est vrai la réitération le
retour en arrière ou le renforcement
mais c'est pas le sujet pour moi ni pour
la république en marche à mon avis parce
que le choix de ce mot renaissance il
pose une question autrement plus basique
je veux dire plus si qu'analytique c'est
ce qui n'est pas née peut-il renaître ce
que pour vous la république en marche ça
n'a jamais marché ben oui six ans après
sa création à la république en marche et
1 et ce qu'on peut ajouter est ce qu'on
peut se transformer tout en restant
soi-même voilà c'est un grand classique
et j'ai joué six ans après sa création
la république en marche c'est un objet
politique non identifié faut se poser la
question à quoi ça sert un parti belle
c'est à fédérer des gens autour d'idées
pour mener un combat politique et à
former des militants à faire émerger des
cadres à se constituer une doctrine à
formuler des propositions à lui faire
vivre dans le débat public et à
conquérir le pouvoir et puis ensuite à
l'exercer or si on met de côté la
réélection de macron ce qui n'est pas
rien quand même entre nous je le
reconnais mais qui tient plus à emmanuel
macron qu'à son propre parti et bien la
république en marche n'a coché quasiment
aucune de ces cases depuis sa création
son patron stanislas guérini l'a presque
surnommé cet inconnu à la tête des
marcheurs en 2018 on pourrait dire
aujourd'hui il est quand même très très
peu connu du grand public ses adhérents
ils sont quand même 429 1280 revendiqué
au 18 mars 2022 elles sont pas pour
autant des militants appellent qu'il
suffit d'un simple clic et qu'en plus
c'est gratuit la doctrine l a jamais eu
de jour personne ne sait ce que c'est
que mme acronis ma part emmanuel macron
parfois encore les propositions de la
république en marche elle était
famélique depuis cinq ans et le parti
manque tellement de cadre que le
président est encore obligé de les
piocher chez ses concurrents pour
essayer de trouver du personnel
politique à la hauteur pour occuper des
ministères par exemple quand on bilan
électoral heures présidentielle vous en
avait parlé il est affligeant lrm a raté
les municipales a raté les
départementales a raté les régionales
elle reste un parti hors sol samson sans
implantation est ce que ça peut changer
oui mais pas en se contentant de changer
de nom est patent que le président
continuera à s'occuper de tout sans
laisser vivre son mouvement un parti
c'est compliqué mais pour qu'il soit
vivant il pouvoir il faut pouvoir y
laisser s'exprimer des sensibilités
différentes là on a l'impression que ça
sera plus chez ensemble caveau qu'au
sein même de renaissance il faut pas
limiter le rôle du parti à celui d'une
chambre d'enregistrement ou à celui d'un
régiment c'est un savant dosage dont les
maquereaux nist n'ont toujours pas
retrouvé la recette en tout cas ils
n'ont pas fait la preuve aujourd'hui
qu'il avait trouvé alexa germond êtes
d'accord sur les lieux il ya beaucoup de
critiques dans cette chronique de
matthieu mais sur l'absence de ligne
politique claire en fait je suis
d'accord sur la dernière partie en fait
de ce que vous venez de dire notamment
sur le fait que cette majorité
présidentielle elle est plurielle et on
voit bien que ça peut s'exprimer et
c'est le challenge mais ça peut et ça
doit s'exprimer au sein d'ensembles ces
différentes approches et ça a été très
bien dit d'ailleurs par richard ferrand
à la fin de la 2 la conférence de presse
quand il dit en fait on verra chacun
pourra trouver finalement une maison qui
lui ressemble là où je suis entièrement
d'accord avec vous c'est sur l'utilité
des partis politiques et d'ailleurs pour
ceux
je le dis puisque j étais au havre
lorsqu'edouard philippe a lancé le
mouvement horizons sont derrière le voir
loin pour faire bien il y a vraiment une
nécessité et une exigence de réflexion
parce que on ne se rend compte aussi
qu'un parti politique un vrai rôle dans
la démocratie il ne faut pas croire que
les partis politiques sont accessoires
du tout et je crois beaucoup vous savez
mon attachement notamment à la réflexion
sur le long terme et je crois qu'il faut
arriver
tout simplement à mettre en commun une
exigeante réflexion voilà parce que
l'état du pays on est vraiment un vin de
carrefour avec des problématiques
sociales des problématiques économiques
des problématiques diplomatiques
militaires j'en passe géopolitique et
seul rien de bon ne peut sortir donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
parliez de la ligne politique
je crois qu'il faut une colonne
vertébrale sur laquelle après vous êtes
capable d'avoir des sensibilités et des
identités différentes qui permettent
c'est pas rassemblés juste pour
rassembler électoralement s'est
rassemblée pour être capable de ne pas
perdre le temps que nous avons devant
nous mais benjamin roll est ce que c'est
possible avec un 1 emmanuel macron qui
disons une conception du poids assez
verticale c'est compliqué en effet parce
qu'en réalité il faut que le parti
puisse servir d'impulsion et que les
idées que fait est formulée au sein du
parti puisse s'imposer au sommet et là
pour le coup on vit quand même un moment
assez
drôle ou en tout cas assez particulier
parce que les partis au 20e siècle sous
la vème république sert notamment au
moment des législatives
c'est à dire que c'est ce moment où en
effet l'incarnation n'est pas suffisante
vous avez besoin d'un programme et vous
avez besoin d'être élu sur un programme
mais c'est le parti qui formalise qui se
construit autour du programme les
élections présidentielles c'est une
élection qui se joue avant tout sur un
ethos sur un personnage qui va être un
personnage charismatique et depuis du
depuis le début du quinquennat et ça
affaiblit tous les partis politiques et
ça induit également la vie politique
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est eh bien
ces partis ont eu un rôle assez
accessoire parce qu'en réalité vous
gagner les présidentielles est
automatiquement vous gagnez législatives
derrière ce qui est intéressant avec ces
législatives c'est ça peut-être être de
vrais législatives on verra bien les
résultats de nos lois qu'on a une
politisation de l'opinion sur ses
législatives qui ne seront pas les
châtie l'habituel ou en réalité
l'électorat de la majorité se sont
remobilisés celui-là de l'opposition se
démobiliser et ça faisait un résultat
automatique oui mais les visages qui
prend le plus de place sur les affiches
seront sans doute ceux de mélenchon mais
emmanuel macron peut-être mais ce sera
pas suffisant on va dire que pour le
coup vous avez besoin de formuler un
programme politique et c'est là où la
majorité aujourd'hui est en difficulté
parce que en effet le parti je rejoins
ce qui a été dit n'a pas existé et pour
le coup un parti c'est deux choses le
parti c'est quelque chose c'est 1-1
objet sociologique c'est quelque chose
qui vous prend à la sortie du lycée qui
vous forme dans les collectivités
territoriales qui forment un personnel
politique
ensuite il peut envoyer à l'assemblée
nationale qui vous apprendre non
seulement parce que comme vous avez fait
toute votre vie dans le parti le jour où
il ya une discipline majoritaire eh bien
vous êtes obligé de la suivent parce que
sinon c'est toute votre vie ailleurs
c'est sartre disait qui est le présent
l'assemblée nationale en s'adressant aux
foals possible transfert il faudra
mais ça ça implique une socialisation au
sein du parti qui n'a pas eu lieu au
sein de la république en marche et
ensuite un parti c'est un objet
idéologique c'est à dire que c'est une
construction intellectuelle et cetera
sur le long terme des amendements sur le
long terme à un programme est ça la
république en marche n'a pas été capable
de le faire donc ça va être un vrai
enjeu pour la république en marche et
pour la suite pour la suite de la vème
république est ce qu'aujourd'hui on est
capable de reproduire des parties michel
llorca dresse sur finalement le
personnalité au personnage ou la
conception du pouvoir des manuels mâcon
dans votre livre vous le qualifiez de
vous dites un populisme d'en haut et du
centre qu'est-ce qui vous mène à cette
analyse à cette critique alors le
populisme pour mario frire des milliers
définition possible enfin c'est un
discours mythique qui prétend reds
régler les contradictions
réelles de la réalité de manière
discursif précisément et donc qui met
ensemble des éléments totalement
contradictoire c'est le fameux en même
temps qui un jour ou l'autre ne peut pas
tenir indéfiniment dont on peut peut
exploser et ça donne une autre chose
donc le populisme c'est ça le populisme
c'est l'idée d'une relation directe
entre le peuple et le pouvoir central le
leader charismatique
même si emmanuel macron n'est pas
particulièrement charismatique m'enfin
quand même et on pourrait en ajouter
mais d'ordinaire les populistes ce qu'on
trouve dans tous les traités de sciences
politiques ou d'histoire il est plutôt
soit d'extrême droite ceux d'extrême
gauche en gros il est de il est plutôt
d'en bas c'est à dire qu'il parle au nom
du peuple il parle au nom d'attendre
populaire ce genre de choses là on a
quelque chose de différent on a un
populisme du centre c'est pas le premier
beppe grillo en italie c'était déjà ça
il était un populisme un coup à gauche
un coup à droite très imprévisible et
donc ça n'a pas plu discours plutôt du
centre et deuxièmement c'est pas un
populisme dambach un appel au peuple
c'est plutôt un populiste qui au nom du
peuple en réalité met en avant la raison
le bon management la bonne gestion etc
donc c'est un peu ça l'idée et je
reviens sur ce que si je peux regarder
ici sur ce qui vient d'être dit parce
que là pour l'instant on voit les choses
d'en haut on voit les têtes de file des
des grands partis discuté négocié etc et
puis ensuite on verra les choses d'en
bas c'est à dire que chaque
circonscription sera différente de la
voisine dans chaque circonscription il
peut y avoir des dissidents il peut y
avoir un candidat qui est ceci ou qui
est ce là par rapport à la sensibilité
d'ensemble des désencrage locaux plus ou
moins solide et bien sûr il y aura la
figure du
de référence mais ça se jouera aussi
beaucoup localement on n'a pas encore
parlé peut-être qu'on va en parler ce
soir de ce qui reste du parti socialiste
en parler mais évidemment que je sur
place ce sera pas simplement
l'application pure et simple sur
désaccord donc ça il ya quelque chose de
très très important et puis j'aurais
juste être très pleinement d'accord mais
malheureusement ça n'est pas les seuls
il ne travaille pas comme disait
monsieur legendre les partis politiques
en général la plus le front national
c'est bien triste à dire de mon point de
vue mais à travailler peut-être un peu
plus que l'autre veut dire qu'il partait
de très loin mais quand même et la
france est soumise voilà ils ont
travaillé dit qu'ils avaient besoin de
crédibilité exactement alors que et ça
permette de derrière la cohésion voilà
sur nous mais enfin le travail tient du
travail mais il est fait à l'elysée il
est fait à matignon il est fait dans les
machines vraiment central du du pouvoir
et je me souviens de ce marché bertrand
je crois le gendre tant que continuerait
le
jean legendre quand il était le patron
de
de la république en marche expliquant on
a été peut-être trop intelligent
voilà ben quand on est trop intelligent
on n'a pas besoin de travailler et donc
ce sont des gens qui n'ont qui n'ont pas
former les jeunes qui n'ont pas créer
des dynamiques qui n'ont pas créé des
clubs de discussions qui n'ont pas des
lieux de réflexion des écoles de
formation quand je pense que la seule
école de formation dont j'ai entendu
parler ces dernières années en france
c'est marion maréchal à lyon avec des
résultats assez médiocres mais c'est
autre chose c'est ça le problème aussi
un sondage qui me semble intéressant
sondage est là pour bfm et l'express
question posée aux sympathisants de la
majorité présidentielle une alliance lrm
modem horizons et agir est elle
souhaitable c'est assez étonnant oui 42%
non 57% et on est très loin des des
réactions des notamment des militants de
gauche ou fin des sympathisants de
gauche ou des sympathisants socialistes
on a donné ces chiffres hier dans cette
émission on était à 80 % de souhaits
d'une union chez les sympathisants de
gauche et à 61 9% et on y reviendra chez
les sympathisants socialistes alexia
germond ça veut dire quoi ça revient ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est ça
peut sembler étonnant cette réaction des
sympathisants c'est ensemble mais avec
eux avec des ententes avec des m6 avait
intégré le fait que des partis comme
horizon ou peut-être comme le modèle
veulent garder leur identité face se
fondre dans un grand parti unique mais
je crois que s'il y avait eu un parti
unique on l'aurait su ce soir dont
l'idée n'est pas celle ci l'idée est
vraiment l'idée d'une confédération mais
parce qu'il doit philippe
et
qui nous accompagnent c'est françois
marne ne l'ont pas souhaité tout
simplement c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya
pas eu un grand parti alors il lomez
identités des autres ils ne l'ont pas
souhaité mais peut-être aussi que ce
n'était pas non plus ce que souhaitaient
les français c'est à dire qu'à un moment
où on a besoin on voit bien qu'il y à
une montée des extrêmes de chaque côté
et je crois que de vouloir fondre une
une identité justement pour faire un
parti unique n'est certainement pas le
meilleur moyen d'arriver à adresser les
sensibilités différentes et ce n'est pas
par hasard si vous avez des gens qui se
sentent mieux au modem d'autres qui se
sentent mieux chez horizon peut-être
qu'un aura d'autres chez territoire de
progrès on n'a pas entendu parler ce
soir pour les investitures donc on voit
bien que ce sont trois trois membres
fondateurs
mais je cours je crois que c'est très
important et c'est certainement intuit
et par par les électeurs qu'il y a pour
ceux qui se sentent très à l'aise avec
les valeurs de centre droit qui sont
également très sensibles aux questions
de d'ordre dans les comptes de d'une
réflexion aussi sur le long terme on
voit bien qu'il y à un parti qui adresse
nouvellement créé mais un parti qui
adressent notamment c'est problématique
là donc je pense que vraiment quand on
parle de sensibilités différentes c'est
la réalité un mot là-dessus ensuite on
passe au sort des ministres non
rapidement mais on
on dit souvent que les identités
politiques sont en perte de vitesse et
c'est vrai vous avez 20 % de lectorat
qu'est une entité politique de gauche 35
à une identité politique de droite mais
malgré tout c'est et nantes et
politiques elles permettent de
synthétiser des choses on le voit
aujourd'hui à gauche il n'y a pas
d'identité politique de la république en
marche et tout le paradoxe est là d'une
certaine façon notamment si on parle de
l'électorat de centre-droit c'est à dire
que eric zemmour lors de la campagne a
voulu dire ben grosso modo je m'adresse
à une identité politique c'est
l'identité politique de droite mais ceux
qui ont une identité politique de droite
la plus ancrée ce sont les personnes
âgées qui votent à droite depuis qu'elle
depuis les années 50 60 70 qui ont voté
pompidou qui ont voter giscard qui ont
voté chirac et caetera et qu'ils se
mettent à voter mâcon et c'est tout le
paradoxe aujourd'hui vous avez des
identités politiques notamment à droite
très très ancrée qui vont voter emmanuel
macron si vous faites une dissolution de
tout ça dans un grand magma et bien à ce
moment là il ya des chances que ces
identités politiques ne retrouvent plus
leurs comptes la force de la majorité
aujourd'hui c'est d'être synthétisée par
un homme qui a reconnu comme étant au
moins par ses électeurs comme étant
charismatique et incarne en quelque
chose mais malgré tout de respecter ces
identités politiques donc là pour le
coup en construisant une majorité de
bric et de broc ça peut poser problème
demain parce qu'on est fait il va
falloir gérer une majorité qui sera
complexe mais pour aujourd'hui pour
s'adresser à ces électeurs là eh bien il
ya nécessité justement de respecter d'où
ils viennent tout ceci à condition de
continuer à penser que le clivage gauche
droite encore un sens pour ses membres
de la cei en iran pourrait peau et pour
une grande partie de l'opinion ce qui
est une vraie question pour 55% des
sciences et non pour 55% des français je
les dis non et pour ces électeurs là oui
alors je les compare des ministres avait
que 3 3 cas d'école en quelque sorte ils
ont le droit vous savez en la prière à
quelques jours de rab jusqu'au 13 mai
extrême limite du de ce premier mandat
d' emmanuel macron alors certains sont
amusé comme jean baptiste djebbar il se
met en scène c'est pour la première fois
sur les réseaux social tik tok regarder
ça commence en effet à être long mais
bon va bene ma bella comme l'a dit un
grand talent
c'est mathieu il est un petit peu en
roue libre non jambes at war il est
souvent olivier minne et des transports
oui
[Applaudissements]
ils se postent sur réseaux sociaux sur
des motos sur les voitures dans des
trains dans des avions moi ce qu'est ce
que je trouve un peu paradoxal c'est
qu'il ya gabriella talent porte parole
du gouvernement nous annonce donc que
ces gouvernements gouvernants aillent
jusqu'au bout il prendra les décisions
nécessaires
il sera là pour agir et protéger les
français jusqu'au 13 mai et on a quoi
jean monnet dans ses cartons sur la
table quasiment on se dira le temps est
long et ils allumèrent de ne plus rien
faire vous regardez des agents
d'administrer des ministres qui n'ont
plus rien à l'heure ajoute on a envoyé à
leurs directeurs de cabinet ça fait
combien de temps maintenant ça fait
presque deux semaines la note leur
donnant la marche à suivre pour quitter
le ministère donc il ose donc on est
dans cette période de transition qui est
une période de grands vides ou là
c'était c'était important que la
majorité reprennent la parole publique
par la voix de des représentants
ensemble qu'on les entende parce que ça
fait quand même quinze jours qu'on
entend des personnes emmanuel macron
obligé de raconter il a continué à faire
campagne un peu comme s'il était
toujours de quoi les sélections et mais
gérer on n'a pas entendu vraiment de
discours à part le soin de du du second
tour et les ministres sont m il existe
en passe qui en plus n'ont pas le temps
de parler pour le rappeler un évènement
macro leur a dit pas de pas d'interview
donc vous n'entendez absolument personne
oui et puis on peut imaginer que même
s'ils avaient le droit peut-être qu'il
ne me ferait très attention parce que la
boue dans le meilleur s'est fait piéger
à la moindre
balle on peut imaginer à 1 re en tout
cas ça a été annoncé comme tel à un
renouvellement important de l'équipe
ministérielle actuels peuvent on
survivra macron 2 bat il va falloir voir
parce que on connaît le problème
inhérent à la macro ni c'est à dire que
vous avez un problème de banc de touche
et donc vous avez un problème à la fois
d'hommes politiques nouveaux et 2 femmes
politiques nouvelles mais également
d'incarnation nouvelle parce qu'en
réalité changer un techno par un autre
techno ça vous donne pas de souffle or
si vous avez gray toi un retardement
aujourd'hui des annonces ministérielles
pour le nouveau gouvernement c'est
justement pour pallier ce qu'on ait
évoqué tout à l'heure on a un grand
temps de latence entre les
présidentielles et législatives si vous
voulez avoir un petit effet de souffle
il faut quand même que votre
gouvernement signifie quelque chose si
vous mettez une liste de ministres
personne ne connaît eh bien ça peut être
relativement problématique donc là vous
avez en effet la nécessité de renouveler
la question s'est renouvelée pourquoi on
verra les surprises s'il y en a qu'on
aura alors autres cas d'école celui du
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire il
a annoncé qu'il ne va pas se représenter
aux législatives c'était dans une
conférence de presse à evreux ce matin
je ne solliciterait pas de quatrième
mandat de député de l'eure lors des
élections législatives des 12 et 19 juin
prochains tout simplement parce que j'ai
toujours dit aux électeurs de la
première c'est conception de leurs que
je ne ferai pas plus de trois mandats
je tiens tout simplement parole
bruno le maire qui est ministre de
l'économie depuis bientôt cinq ans à
d'ailleurs il va battre de quelques
jours le record seul valéry giscard
d'estaing avait tenu aussi aussi
longtemps quatre ans 11 mois et 8 jours
et donc bono le maire il n'y aura un
petit peu plus loin c'est s'est pas
totalement anecdotiques comme chef burqa
est ce que vous êtes quand même très
critique avec emmanuel macron dans votre
livre est ce que la stabilité à ce poste
c'est quand même un bon point pour ce
premier mandat d' emmanuel macron ya vu
une telle valse de ministre de
l'économie dans les années précédentes
que ça a pu faire du bien peut-être je
vais élargit d'abord votre constat tout
n'est pas négatif à mes yeux dans ce qui
a été fait pendant cinq ans évidemment
moi j'ai choisi un angle précis
l'absence ou le manque ou les carences
en matière démocratique mais voilà je
pense qu'effectivement et bruno le maire
je pense a été appréciée pendant la
pandémie
les mesures qu'il a proposées qui là
qu'il a bouclé mise en oeuvre on était
dans son bien passé donc voilà alors bon
il nous dit je ne peux pas me
représenter je n'ai qu'une parole c'est
tout à son honneur je pense aussi que ça
quelques ce laval mes engagements qu'ils
ont été faits
d'une façon ou d'une autre de ne pas
être purement et simplement débarquer
donc je pense que je pense que c'est une
façon de le laisser comprendre qu'il
aura des responsabilités les mêmes ou
d'autres je ne sais pas par la suite
d'accords autres ministres qui pèse dans
ce gouvernement castex encore présents
gérald darmanin lumineuse de l'intérieur
alors lui au contraire il a confirmé sa
candidature dans le nord c'est
intéressant parce que dans sa première
déclaration
cet ancien élève je vous le rappelle a
tout de suite lancé un appel aux
électeurs de la gauche social-démocrate
écoutez nous voulons appeler à 20 sont
évidemment les électeurs de gauche qui
ne se reconnaissent pas dans les
extrémités monsieur mélenchon qui
n'aiment pas les forces de l'ordre qui
une conception très particulière la
façon les joueurs travaillent et qui
veulent absolument augmenter les impôts
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est que comme
ça qu'on arrivera à faire avancer le
pays bas nous leur disons puisque vous
êtes raisonnable considérer que nous
sommes vos meilleurs représentants je
crois savoir qu'une grande partie des
électeurs de gauche ne sont extrêmement
déçus voire extrêmement blessé de cette
trahison du parti socialiste vous
éviterez directement et ça ça
m'intéresse parce que là on voit un axe
de campagne certains sans qui ce qui se
dessine et pas seulement pour gérald
darmanin dans le nord non parce que ça
touche sa touche de toute façon une
fracture qu'on est en train de voir là
la recomposition de de la cartographie
politique
avec quand même un renoncement pour le
parti socialiste pour les verts a des
convictions
grâce à la maestria aussi de jean luc
mélenchon qui a su faire qu'on ne
partage pas ses idées ça c'est une chose
mais il a su réussir ce qu'il n'avait
pas réussi en 2017 c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas laissé le seul temps du souffle
à quiconque de ses colistiers on va dire
potentiel ce qu aurait pu être des
colistiers à la présidentielle et il a
réussi à construire quelque chose en les
étouffant et ans
en réussissant à les faire renoncer à
leurs convictions pour finalement sauvé
leur parti et ça ça va être une ligne de
crête extrêmement clivante pour le coup
et on le voit bien d'ailleurs au niveau
national mais ce sera pareil au niveau
des circonscriptions avec des électeurs
sincère de gauche claire et droits dans
leurs bottes sur les questions de
laïcité d'europe et est également
d'économie da proches économique qui ne
vont pas se retrouver dans cette unité
là qui est proposé et qui pourront
potentiellement aller vers un discours
très pragmatique
est notamment très clair vis-à-vis des
forces de l'ordre vis-à-vis de
l'utilisation de l'argent public
et du prisme économique finalement qui
est qui est porté c'est on voit bien
tout le talent politique de gérald
darmanin très rapidement la cet accord
entre le parti socialiste et la france
insoumise alors à l'heure où je vous
parle il n'a pas encore été validé par
le parlement du parlement interne du ps
le premier secrétaire olivier faure le
défendent et ce matin c'était sur bfm tv
on écoute olivier faur mon honneur
après l'hymne de madame c'est de servir
la gauche c'est d'être de ceux qui
aujourd'hui vont permettre peut-être à
la gauche de retrouver le pouvoir dans
les sondages la coalition que nous
formons elle est à 36 % 9 points devant
la république en marche et ses alliés
mon honneur c'est de faire en sorte que
cet attelage là puisse aller à son terme
faire en sorte que les françaises et les
français qui souffrent puissent
retrouver une forme d'espérance avec
nous c'est ça mon honneur mais mais on
va le voir tout de suite avec alexandre
poussa on peut nous rejoindre mon soir
alexandre 7,9 cet accord parti
socialiste
la france insoumise il entraîne d'ores
et déjà des annonces de candidatures
dissidentes
oui certains ne sont pas d'accord chez
les socialistes et d'ailleurs cette
dissidence socialiste elle a déjà
commencé sous la houlette de carole
delga la présidente de la région
occitanie elle présente des candidatures
dans certains départements de
l'occitanie sans tenir compte de
l'accord avec la france insoumise et
quitte même à affronter et bien aux
législatives des candidats de cette
union de la gauche elle s'explique elle
le dit lorsque nous avons des candidats
qui incarne un projet différent de la
france insoumise et bien nous estimons
que nous avons légitimité à les
présenter en revanche on ne le fera pas
dans certaines circonscriptions
l'extrême droite est en position de
gagner comme dans les pyrénées
orientales où le gard en tout cas il ya
un département dans cette région où il y
aura et bien une forte dissidence c'est
le département de l'hérault car selon
l'accord de ces quatre partis de gauche
et bien dans l'hérault il n'y aura
aucune circonscription pour les
socialistes alors qu'ils sont quand même
très implanté dans ce département ils
ont notamment à la mairie de montpellier
et donc résultats et bien hier carole
delga a participé à la présentation de
trois candidats dans trois
circonscriptions de l'hérault et cette
situation elle est très bien résumé par
le sénateur socialiste de l'hérault
hussein bourgi il le dit l'accord
national d'olivier fort dans l'hérault
on s'assoit dessus et confortablement
voilà qui est dit et puis un autre
département en france où et on devrait
voir et bien des candidatures
socialistes dissidente ces deux
départements de la moselle puisque et
bien cette semaine la fédération
socialiste de moselle a déjà dit qu'elle
pourrait présenter et bien des 10 des
dissidents dans au moins sept
circonscriptions sur neuf alors une
question se pose seins qui pour mener
cette campagne des dissidents
socialistes et bien il y a un ancien
ministre de françois hollande qui est
prêt pour le faire c'est stéphane le
foll ya une campagne législative qu'il
faudra conduire pour tous ces candidats
pour certains qui sont dans l'accord
mais pour tous ceux qui vont être
candidat quand même parce qu'ils
n'accepteront pas l'accord il faut
conduire cette compacte ses fans au vol
qui va donc conduire cette campagne aux
côtés des dissidents socialistes et puis
après il verra si il quitte le ps voilà
pour les socialistes dans les autres
parties de cette nouvelle union
populaire il ya aussi enfin qui voit là
des dissidents qui se sont exprimées
alors chez europe ecologie les verts eh
bien on a plutôt digérer accepté cet
accord avec la france insoumise en
revanche chez les communistes il ya déjà
des dissidents qui sont déclarés
notamment à vénissieux dans la banlieue
de lyon la maire communiste de
vénissieux michèle picard et bien
maintient sa candidature face au
candidat investi par la france soumise à
à boisse militants journalistes c'est
d'ailleurs celui qui a filmé alexandre
bénin en train de frapper des
manifestants place de la contrescarpe à
paris une candidature de taabo à ce qui
est bien pour un faux créé la polémique
car il a été condamné par la justice oui
pour injure raciale c'est ça le trompe
merci beaucoup alexandre poussé à
l'excès germond quel destin pour ces
dissidents parce que sans parti
politique peut-être son financement
enfin que vous touchez du doigt la à la
fois on peut on peut saluer pour moi je
salue toujours le respect des
convictions on peut ne pas avoir les
mêmes mais des des candidats qui sont
investis qui depuis longtemps travail
leur territoire c'est aussi beaucoup
d'engagement le l'engagement dans le
débat public qui se voit aujourd'hui qui
ne se reconnaissent pas dans une dans
une un accord
qu'ils aient envie néanmoins d'être
dissidents c'est quelque chose que l'on
peut je trouve ça lui et après il ya la
réalité qui revient en boomerang c'est à
dire qu'on s'est même sur des campagnes
qui ne sont raisonnables du point de vue
financier parce que les législatives le
sont en général c'est évidemment pas les
mêmes montants mais il faut des moyens
il faut une organisation
il faut une structuration et donc c'est
vrai que vous avez très bien résumé la
situation
au delà de l'envi il faut aussi les
capacités après sur le terrain d'aller
affronter avec des financements qui sont
difficiles je partage tout à fait votre
avis mais je mettrais une petite nuance
cedac les nouveaux candidats n'ont
aucune chance on dispense c'est très
très compliqué ah oui quand vous êtes
implantés localement implantés
localement vous êtes une figure et ben
vous pouvez tout à fait réussir il ya
des cas par le passé il a les plus
faibles dans l'histoire récente et
olivier falorni le maire je me souvenais
de la rochelle qui affrontait en
décidant
ségolène royal rien là et qu'il avait
battu parce que l'ufr falorni était à la
rochelle depuis toujours et été et est
mieux implanté que ségolène royal là bas
donc ça peut ça peut marcher quand vous
êtes une figure locale et c'est cela qui
est intéressant ce jeu faisait référence
à sa évidemment puisque l'idée même d'un
accord c'est quoi c'est que vous avez
certains qui étaient sortants qui sont
pas reconduits quand ils n'étaient pas
de la france insoumise donc on voit bien
aimé les ps rihanna sait c'est qu'il
avait présentées 395 candidats 2010cinq
c'est conscient
qu'elle peau de chagrin quelle peau de
chagrin donc il déçu alors je pense
qu'il faut concevoir qu'il réfléchisse à
la structuration politique de cette
dissidence la dissidence quand on pense
à ce qu'elle a été en union soviétique
c'était des personnes très isolé tout
seul là on a affaire quand même beaucoup
de monde et donc est ce qu'il va y avoir
un nouveau parti est ce qu'ils vont
créer un parti c'est pas un peu aussi
est ce que on ne sait pas encore ce que
ce que sera le vote
ce soir du
leu à
l'europarlement le nom de parti
socialiste ne s'est pas évident qui va
se partager les maigres reste de ceux de
ce2 de ce nom ça c'est quand même des
choses qui sont qui sont très très très
sévères je viens pour vous le ps aura
vécu 51 ans connaît ce ps là pour moi
nous vivons son agonie alors soit il se
fait comme on dirait la vallée est
digérée et le côté france insoumise soit
il il est encore plus marginal qu'il a
été ces derniers temps avec un réseau
d'élus locaux je pense il d'ailleurs il
a toujours été un set soir était un
socialisme municipal le socialisme
français ça n'a jamais été une
social-démocratie jeu le duo fin mai est
ce que dans ce cas là ils vont créer une
force politique structuré se doter d'un
nom d'une étiquette est ce qu'ils vont
mettre en avant des personnalités dont
les français n'ont pas voulu si on dit
aux français vous avez un nouveau parti
socialiste dissident ou ou réunifiée ou
que sais-je on y trouveront bien non
dont un des principaux dirigeants et
françois hollande une autre principales
dirigeantes et anne hidalgo les
ça donnera quand même une image de
patrie curieuse vision oui je suis
répugnance et c'est à dire que très
clairement il ya plusieurs choses qui
sont passés d'abord l'électorat social
démocrate est passé chez emmanuel macron
donc à partir de là il n'y a pas
réellement des espaces politiques
aujourd'hui pour un parti qui serait
uniquement un parti de centre gauche
donc faire exister quelque chose sur un
très courte en face d'un côté les filles
et de l'autre à la république en marche
sa part et par renaissance maintenant ça
paraît relativement compliqué par
ailleurs au sein du parti socialiste on
l'a dit sur les dissidents mais vous
n'avez une chance en tant qu dissidents
que si l'élection est peu nationalisée
or visiblement elle va être très
nationalisée si vous êtes très très bien
implanté et si la circonscription
apparaît comme un fief parce que sinon
vous neutralisé avec l'autre candidat et
les deux disparaissent donc
fondamentalement ça va peut-être se
passer et dans très peu de
circonscriptions s'est quand même passé
quelque chose depuis hier c'est que les
maires des grandes villes qui en fait
sont ceux qui ont raymond
pouvoir antennes territoriales rennes
nantes clermont ferrand lille et cetera
ont annoncé y compris anne hidalgo qu'il
soutiendrait même si certains à reculons
l'accord vous avez les présidents de
région carole delga jld s'était girard
ex état mais qui sont loin d'être ceux
qui sont les mieux implantés en réalité
qui refusent l'accord mais du point de
vue du socialisme justement plutôt
municipal pour l'instant ça suit merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat michel llorca je rappelle le
titre de votre livre alors monsieur
macron heureux publié aux éditions rue
de seine